in 2009 this disease infected millions
of people now it could be back this is
the swine flu although we managed to
largely avoid it over ten years ago
there's now a new strain of the virus
and experts think that this new strain
has the potential to cause another
worldwide pandemic how likely is this to
happen what would happen if you caught
this disease and how does this virus
compared to kovat 19 this is what if and
here's what would happen if you caught
the swine flu this new strand of h1n1 or
swine flu is known as the g4 virus it
comes from pigs and has been
transferring to humans for a couple of
years now
based on early lab tests this virus has
remnants of the 2009 swine flu pandemic
as well as the Spanish flu meaning that
this new strain could possibly cause
another worldwide pandemic so what would
happen if you caught this disease one
tenth of people in China who work in the
pig industry have caught this new swine
flu if the g4 strain is similar to the
original swine flu here's what you could
expect if you happened to accidentally
touch an infected surface or get sneezed
on by someone with swine flu then
there's a chance you could get it that's
how the disease has spread once the
virus enters your body it might take one
to four days before you really start to
notice anything and the symptoms you do
experience might be pretty similar to
something you've experienced before
the first day you'd likely get a fever
and some chills at one point you'd be
sweating and the next your entire body
might be freezing this would also be
accompanied by muscle aches and general
fatigue you'll need to stay away from
people as you could easily infect others
during this time after a day or two go
by you could also be met with a cough
runny nose and some sneezing
during the original swine flu some
patients also reported having diarrhea
but it didn't happen to everyone at this
point just stay in your bed and rest
drink lots of water and do what you can
to heal up the vast majority of people
who catch swine flu are most likely to
experience something along these lines
and after a little more than a week you
should be good as new
but there is a slight chance that these
issues could get worse if these symptoms
last more than a week you could develop
pneumonia or respiratory issues if you
start to have a tough time breathing it
would be best to contact a doctor or get
to a hospital they'll be able to give
you the medical treatment you need it's
quite rare that you die from swine flu
but not impossible according to the
Centers for Disease Control over 150
thousand people died from it in 2009
this was most likely due to the
pneumonia or breathing issues that the
virus can cause or the fact that getting
the flu can affect any previous medical
issues that people have had so we know
what to expect if you get it but could
this g4 virus start a new pandemic
well according to experts you shouldn't
be too worried at least not yet
this g4 strain of the virus has been
around for over five years and has yet
to severely spread not only that but
it's only been able to spread from pigs
to people rather than through the
population also remember that when swine
flu was at its peak in 2009 a person who
had the disease would only affect on
average less than two people this is
less infectious than kovat 19 according
to recent studies a person with kovat 19
can infect five to six people not only
that but dealing with swine flu is a lot
easier than dealing with kovat 19 since
the virus is more similar to things
we've had in our system before kovat 19
is so dangerous because it's something
humans have never experienced that being
said we probably shouldn't just brush
this off what can we do to avoid this
virus and all other viruses well the
best thing you can do is wash your hands
often don't touch your face and practice
social distancing and while you're at it
would you wear a mask okay
don't be like her and just wear a mask
now since you're wearing a mask what if
everyone on the planet decided to wear
one well we'll leave that story for
another
[Music]
you